if you've managed to secure a ps5 during
its first year on the market there are
plenty of top-notch games you can enjoy
with your kids in today's video i'll
give you 10 of my favorite ps5 titles
that would make excellent gifts this
holiday season and don't worry i'll do a
quick recap of all 10 games at the end
and also include links to all of them in
the description below today's video
we'll start off the list with what is
undoubtedly my favorite ps5 game to play
with my son sack boy a big adventure
it's actually one of the best
platformers i have played in years not
even kidding here seriously guys we're
talking nintendo and mario level quality
here if you remember the old little big
planet games that formula goes almost
completely out the window with a big
adventure the latter is a 3d platformer
developed by sumo digital and not media
molecule the original creators of the
series the game is divided up into a
series of hub worlds and while it's
described as a 3d platformer there are a
number of different ways sumo switches
up to perspective throughout the game
with tweaks to level design along the
way it does operate from a fixed camera
perspective which kind of gives it the
feel of something like super mario 3d
world each level has a ton of
collectibles to find and challenges to
complete there are hundreds of different
costume pieces for your sackboy some of
which are found hidden throughout the
levels and others you can purchase with
gold you collect in-game sacboy manages
to strike that perfect balance of
presenting just enough of a challenge to
be difficult but not too frustrating for
inexperienced gamers to lose interest
although you can play sackboy solo the
game shines brightest when you play
alongside a friend or even a group of
friends a total of four players can team
up and while online play is supported my
son and i had an absolute blast playing
at his couch co-op seriously just so
many laughs i cannot recommend this game
enough up next we have ratchet and clank
rift apart which is a brand new entry in
the popular series from insomniac this
one is an absolute
graphical stunner on the ps5 hardware
and has received near unanimous praise
from fans and media alike if you've
played a ratchet game before you'll know
what to expect here if not imagine a
high-energy third-person shooting game
with off-the-wall weapons packaged
together in an experience that looks
like a pixar movie plus a fun story to
tie it all together where rift apart
iterates on the established formula is
by introducing rifts throughout the game
which open portals to other worlds
players can use these rifts to jump to
other locations in the game almost
instantly this sets the stage for unique
gameplay moments unlike what you've
experienced in the series before it's so
incredibly clear playing through this
game just how much insomniac has
mastered their craft over the years the
levels are just absolutely brilliant the
gameplay fun and engaging and did i
mention just how gorgeous it all is our
next title is a fresh take on a
platforming classic it's crash bandicoot
4 it's about time now if you're an old
school gamer like me you may be thinking
i'm incredibly cruel to recommend a
crash game for kids when you consider
just how tough the original games were
and don't get me wrong they were pretty
tough but you'll be happy to know crash
4 should please both new and retro
gamers by offering two difficulty
options modern which is more accessible
for new players and retro which will
appeal more to the hardcore fans of the
series regardless of which difficulty
you play on the game feels like classic
crash with a fresh coat of paint and
some new enhancements reviewers praised
the game for its quick and challenging
platforming beautiful environments and
strong replayability thanks to bonus
flashback levels local co-op competitive
multiplayer and plenty of unlockables
for something the whole family can enjoy
check out overcooked all you can eat
which is a compilation of both the
original overcooked and overcooked 2. if
you've never played an overcooked game
before it doesn't take long for things
to get just outright ridiculous the
setup is pretty straightforward prepare
food for customers in a given amount of
time but then you know the game's going
to throw plenty of obstacles along the
way that's going to make this a much
easier task said than a task done the
levels shift change and add new elements
as you try to progress which only result
in more insane moments this is one of
those titles where you'll probably want
to check your competitive ego at the
door and just enjoy the journey after
all i can't promise this one won't
result in some shouting and yelling as
you try and coordinate with your family
members to complete the orders
accurately and on time now our next
title is one that's completely free
that's right as long as you own a ps5
you can get this title totally free in
fact it's the very first game that i
recommend you boot up when you get your
ps5 it's astros playroom which is a game
that completely blew me away my son
who's a huge fan of mario games has also
enjoyed astro's playroom immensely it
was really his first introduction to
playstation to be honest i can't think
of a better way for a kid to learn about
playstation for the first time like i
mentioned i love this game so much it's
definitely the first one you should play
when you put up the system for the first
time it's a 3d platforming adventure
that will take you through the history
of playstation it also serves as an
incredible showcase for the new dual
sense controller and while astro is an
absolutely phenomenal showcase for the
controller the fact that it ends up
being so much more than that is what i
truly found surprising you'll move about
a series of different worlds that
represent generations of playstation
consoles astro will take on various
enemies and platform challenges along
the way you'll have a simple punch
attack spin attack and laser when astro
hovers to help you take care of the
enemies there are collectible puzzle
pieces and artifacts to find in each
world the puzzle pieces you find are
added to a giant puzzle in the game's
hub area whereas the artifacts are
pieces of playstation's history that
also make their way into that hub with
astros playroom it's all about the tiny
little details of nostalgia that really
helped to put it over the top there's so
many little nods and secrets that i just
don't want to even try and spoil them
all here it's far better if you
experience these for yourself the game
will only take you about four to six
hours to complete and really that's
honestly the only problem i had with it
after it was over i just wanted more
both my son and i were sad to see it end
but what a ride it was hopefully this is
only the beginning for astro on ps5
because i would honestly love to see a
sobe team get a shot at making a full
length 3d platformer featuring astro now
while astro is a celebration of all
things playstation one of the first pc
titles i ever played as a kid was sim
theme park unfortunately that series
isn't around anymore today but planet
coaster may be the next best thing like
sim theme park and roller coaster tycoon
before it planet coaster is a strategy
game where players set up and manage
theme parks there are four primary modes
in the game career sandbox challenge and
a scenario editor players become a theme
park manager in the career mode and are
tasked with completing various scenarios
to earn a bronze silver or gold star
which factor into your overall career
level then there's sandbox mode which
allows you to create your own theme park
by shaping the land building up your own
roller coasters and setting up
concession stands with this one you'll
also have unlimited funds and where
sandbox mode is all about the fun
challenge mode is harder and you'll only
start with a small amount of money this
one places much more of an emphasis on
the funds that you have coming in to
help sustain your park the scenario
editor allows players to create their
own scenarios which can then be played
in the career mode or uploaded online to
challenge other players you know one of
the wonderful things about video games
is just how many different types of
experiences you can enjoy and our next
game is completely different from
something like planet coaster it's
chicory a colorful tale which is an
absolutely
gorgeous and charming title you can
enjoy on the ps5 chicory is essentially
a giant coloring book that tells a
unique story from a top-down perspective
chicory is the lone wielder of a magic
brush that adds vibrancy and color to
what is otherwise a simple world of
black and white when chicory
unexpectedly abandons her post as the
wielder our main character who's a
janitor at the wielder's tower takes it
upon herself to pick up the brush and
restore color to the world the painting
mechanic throughout the game is deeper
than you'd expect and you'll gain access
to multiple tools along your adventure
many reviewers praised chicory for its
accessibility to players of any skill
level you can tweak not only the
difficulty of combat but also that of
the puzzles in addition to the gameplay
it tells a very touching sympathetic
story which i won't spoil here when it
comes to playing with family or friends
this is one that's beautiful to watch
and also supports co-op play where a
friend can paint alongside you if you
have a kid who's more of the laid back
artistic type then you certainly can't
go wrong with a title like chicory up
next we have temtem a title that's
unabashedly inspired by pokemon but just
so happens to be a solid game in its own
right temtim is a massively multiplayer
creature collection adventure players
will catch tempt him and battle other
tamers sound familiar yet you can also
customize your house join a friend's
adventure or explore the six islands of
the airborne archipelago there's a story
campaign where you'll travel across
those six islands while doing battle
against an evil clan look the
similarities to pokemon are certainly
there but where nintendo series has
resisted turning into an mmo temtem
fully embraces it in temtem players from
around the world can join you in real
time living the adventure alongside you
and battling to become a top tamer
there's also a co-op adventure mode
multiple customization options and
competitive play one of the best aspects
of temtem is how new content is
constantly being added to the game in
the form of new events new missions new
cosmetics and even new temtem for the
older kids out there they may be ready
to try a teen rated title like kana
bridge of spirits kana is a 2021
action-adventure title from ember lab
and it's another on our list with
absolutely gorgeous graphics and art
design kana is a young spirit guide
who's been tasked with helping spirits
find eternal rest you'll control the
heroine from a third-person perspective
and use your staff to battle enemies
using light heavy and charged attacks
kanan will also collect spirit
companions known as rot along the way
the rot will aid kana in a number of
different ways throughout the adventure
this one lands that teen rating as it
does tend to focus more on mature themes
like death grief and forgiveness if
you've been curious about the battle
royale craze but prefer something a
little more lighthearted than say
fortnite you and the family should check
out fall guys ultimate knockout my son
and i played a ton of this one when it
first released and it's good to see fall
guys is still going strong today up to
60 players will drop in each game to try
and make their way through a series of
zany challenges while controlling
bizarre jelly bean shaped characters
only so many will make it through each
round until one is crowned the victor at
the very end some of the levels are set
up like an obstacle course with clear
inspiration from classic platformers
like mario galaxy and even tv shows like
wipeout there are also team-based levels
where players are randomly assigned a
team and then must work together with
other jelly beans to best the other team
the losing team's players are all
eliminated developer mediatonic has
worked hard to keep the game fresh and
they've added new themed seasons which
often come with new levels game modes
and cosmetics look i also have a video
up for the best switch games for kids
which you can check out on the left side
of your screen right now and as always
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon